[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: So
one of the things
that happens when we grow
older, with our nodding
resignation into
nothingness, is that we
enter a kind of
consciousness known
as "the been there's and done
that's" of the adult mind.
It's that notion when nothing
excites or overwhelms anymore,
because you've
seen it all before.
What a tragedy this is, right?
I mean, come on!
I mean we all
remember nostalgically
the intensity of experiencing
something for the first time,
seeing the world through
the eyes of child-- wonder
struck, entranced by awe.
Succumbing to astonishment,
giving in to astonishment,
mouth gaped wide, I mean
damn to see something
for the first time.
But then what happens then,
you assimilate, you model it
in your brain, you
store it in your library
of been there's and done that's
and you no longer engage,
right-- sensorily with stimuli.
It's called hedonic adaptation.
Familiarity breeds boredom.
It's so depressing, right?
And so what do we do?
I think this is where mindful
self-inquiry comes in.
This is where meditation-- this
is where breathing exercises,
and yoga comes in.
This is where boarding a craft
that flies you across the world
can be therapeutic
like to injecting you
with a little bit of
life by stimulating
you, and jet-lagging
you, and placing you
with an entirely different
wallpaper of the mind.
That's why travel revitalizes.
It's why people self-medicate.
Sometimes tweaking our
perception, sometimes
that marijuana joint, can be
the magnifying lens or the pane
of glass that doesn't
distort reality,
but confers our phenomenon--
a certain feeling of distance
as David Lancet says.
Perhaps that's why a museum
takes an ordinary item
and puts it on the wall,
decontextualizes it, and brings
our attention back to it.
We get to enter the
archetypical space
where the specific stands
in for all of it's kind--
stands in for the
reversal, right?
We like to enter a modality
of consciousness known
as Plato's Realm of Ideas.
I mean, that's where
you live in the present.
That's when anxiety about
the future and melancholy
for the past get drowned out
by the ever present rapture
of the now.
And we are free!
And in that moment
we are Adam and Eve
in the Garden of
Eden before eating
from the Tree of Knowledge--
knowing no death,
knowing only now and
the bliss of now.
If only we could get back there.
I support whatever
works-- as long
as you don't hurt anybody else.
[MUSIC PLAYING]